thomas bonsoir vous êtes toujours à new
york
vous suivez ces élections alors il y a
environ 20 minutes donald trump s'est
exprimé il revendique déjà sa victoire
qu'elle est actuellement l'atmosphère à
new york
pas beaucoup de monde je sais que les
gens sont étaient présents ils sont
rentrés chez eux pour suivre justement
les résultats
un peu à l'image du pays les new-yorkais
ont assez vite compris que l'issue du
scrutin ne se jouera pas cette nuit les
résultats sont tellement serré qu'il est
impossible d'annoncer un vainqueur à
l'heure où je vous parle évidemment les
yeux sont désormais rivés vers ces
fameux swing states qui pourront faire
basculer l'élection on pense au risque
sinon pense au michigan mais surtout
l'état de pennsylvanie les résultats
sont donc très serré ça a été le cas
notamment dans le texas c'est le cas en
arizona et finalement c'est joe biden
qui a pris la parole le premier cette
nuit depuis le delaware vous allez
l'entendre l'ancien vice-président
résolument optimiste
je suis venu vous dire que nous pensons
être en bonne voie pour gagner cette
élection
nous savions qu'avec un nombre inédit de
vote par anticipation et par
correspondance cela va prendre du temps
il va falloir être patient jusqu'à ce
que le difficile décompte des votes soit
terminé est ce que jusqu'à ce que chaque
vote
chaque bulletin soit compté mais nous
sommes confiants sur notre position nous
pourrions avoir des résultats demain
matin mais ça pourrait prendre un peu
plus de temps comme je les ai toujours
dit mais ce n'est pas à moi ou à donald
trump de prononcer des résultats de
cette élection c'est au peuple américain
de le faire mais je reste optimiste
et puis c'est donc donald trump qui
s'est exprimé dans une conférence de
presse qu il a décrit lui même comme une
des plus tardive de son mandat il s'est
exprimé pour revendiquer une victoire
malgré le fait que le décompte n'est pas
tout à fait terminée dans un certain
nombre d'états il a également parlé d'un
petit groupe de gens très triste qui
sont en train d'essayer de lui voler
l'élection ce sont les mots du locataire
de la maison blanche
écoutez donald trump lors de cette prise
de parole il ya quelques instants
on est en train de gagner en
pennsylvanie avec une marge considérable
nous avons remporté plusieurs états et
soudain je me suis dit mais qu'est-il
arrivé à l'élection est annulée
je ne sais pas beaucoup de gens se
demandent ce qu'il se passe en fait ils
savaient qu'ils ne pouvaient pas gagner
donc ils ont dit qu'ils allaient saisir
la cour suprême ne lâche pas prédit gelé
prédit depuis le jour où j'ai su qu'ils
allaient envoyer des dizaines de
milliers de bulletins de vote par
correspondance
c'est exactement ce que j'avais prédit
où il gagne où ils nous font passer
devant la cour suprême
c'est une fraude contre le peuple
américain c'est une honte pour notre
pays nous nous attendions a gagné cette
élection et honnêtement nous l'avons
gagnée notre objectif maintenant c'est
une question d'intégrité pour le bien du
pays
c'est une fraude contre notre pays nous
voulons que la loi soit appliquée comme
il se doit
donc nous allons passer devant la cour
suprême nous voulons que le vote
s'arrête on ne veut pas qu'ils se
rajoutent des bulletins de vote à 4
heures du matin et qui les ajoute au
total
voilà pour cette prise de parole
fracassante de donald trump vous l'aurez
compris joe biden estime qu'il est sur
la bonne voie pour remporter cette
élection de trump à viande de sa part
pour sa part qu'il a déjà remporté cette
élection c'est donc la confusion qui
règne ici pas de vainqueur pour le
moment je vous le rappelle les
dépouillement est toujours en cours et
pourrait même durer plusieurs jours dans
l'état de pennsylvanie où le vote par
courrier le vote en avance a été
plébiscitée dans cet état qui est un
état clé pour cette élection il ya en
tout cas un enseignement à tirer de
cette première nuit d' élections
américaines c'est le fait que les
sondages se sont lourdement trompés il
est annoncé pour la plupart un avantage
assez nette pour joe biden dans un
certain nombre d'états et finalement les
premières estimations et les premiers
résultats qui nous parviennent
hamon montre un scrutin bien plus serré
qu'il n'y paraît merci beaucoup
thomas bonnet pour tous et président
précision en direct de new york